Привет! Это восьмой урок модуля. К этому моменту в проекте у тебя уже есть Warframe, есть UI-кит из уроков 5, 6, 7, компоненты, состояния, variables и так далее.
Самый простой способ соединить их — пройтись и положить инстансы из дизайн-системы поверх каждого прямоугольника Warframe, ну это грубо говоря.
Но тогда получится сырой экран. Не будет иконок, будут серые квадраты, останутся сущности, которые описаны просто текстом в нашем Warframe.
Все, конечно, нужно дорабатывать. Вообще, в идеале, конечно, на Warframe ты все эти сущности хотя бы маломальски визуализируешь, но не всегда получается.
Хочется поскорее перейти к макетам и, как правило, в Warframe ты описываешь конкретную логику поведения, в общем-то, в общем, прям фундамент.
И, конечно, этот фундамент назвать готовыми экранами нельзя. Мы будем пользоваться директивой Final Screens и она устроена иначе, чем просто пересобери то, что уже есть.
Она не просто переводит Warframe в компоненты, она доращивает Warframe до Production и на лету выносит повторяющиеся блоки в UIKit.
Все в одном прогоне.
Этим мы сегодня и займемся.
Итак, как я уже ранее сказал, у нас на входе достаточно сырые данные.
Да, есть база компонентов самых основных, есть какой-то каркас секций, но это все визуализировать нужно как-то иначе.
Эти сущности нужно представить в удобном, понятном виде.
У меня речь идет о серверах, там их описание изложено через точки Ubuntu, IMS, 2CPU и так далее.
EdgeCases нет, состояния многие пустые там, потому что заложено только ровно то, что там нужно, именно сухая логика.
Поэтому все это нужно дорастить.
Для этого у нас предусмотрено 4 дополнительных фазы в этой нашей директиве.
Во-первых, первая фаза Preflight.
В ней он спрашивает, нужны ли тебе вообще иконки, какие иконки ты хочешь использовать.
По умолчанию он берет иконки библиотеки Lucid.
Они, на мой взгляд, такие самые нейтральные.
Также еще раз сканят, что у тебя вообще есть в твоей библиотеке, что уже предусмотрено и используют на полную катушку все свои возможности.
Еще раз отмечу, что глобально она перерисовывает Warframe, собирая на компонентах, которые у тебя есть.
И конкретно этот функционал, я считаю, нет смысла описывать.
Здесь же вынесены основные особенности, которые делают эту директиву действительно полезной.
Следующая фаза, которая немного выбивается из процесса, это анализ достаточности Warframe.
Возможно, у тебя в Warframe не все описано, возможно, ты не все визуализировал.
Посмотрел, такой вроде норм и двигаешься дальше.
Поскольку мы сейчас двигаемся по домашним заданиям и смотрим именно функциональность, скорее всего, так у тебя и выглядит твой Warframe.
Поэтому в эту директиву я внедрил анализ достаточности.
То, насколько у тебя все подробно расписано и действительно этим можно пользоваться.
Исходя из этого, он проектирует логику тех экранов, которые будет отрисовывать.
И здесь мы уже можем переключаться на следующую фазу.
У нас появятся новые повторяющиеся блоки, у нас появятся новые сущности и так далее.
И все это он снова будет сравнивать с компонентной базой, что уже есть.
Может быть, какие-то атомы можно внедрить в эти новые компоненты.
Отслеживает, в общем, то, что повторяется и еще раз у тебя опрувет.
Мы добавляем это в компонентную базу или нет.
Сразу отмечу, что мы пользуемся не какой-то программой, которую один раз написали, а агентом и директивами.
Поэтому, если ты не хочешь, чтобы он тебя брифовал, если не хочешь, чтобы спрашивал каждое действие, ты можешь запросто сказать ему, делай все на свое усмотрение.
И вот эти шаги брифования будут пропущены.
Ну и последний пункт, это прежде чем создавать все эти новые компоненты, отрисовывать новые экраны, он проверяет, чтобы все нормально собрал, записал в существующую дизайн-систему внутри твоей среды и можно переходить уже к отрисовке.
Давай сразу отметим, что от этой директивы можно ожидать, в чем она хороша, а в чем не очень.
Во-первых, стабильно она делает типовые экраны с какими-то стандартными секциями.
Дашборды, списки, настройки и так далее.
Чтобы предугадать, что она сделает хорошо, задай себе вопрос, как много приложений есть с этим экраном.
Если это какие-нибудь настройки или редактирование профиля, мы знаем, что каким бы задачам не отвечало приложение, там это скорее всего есть.
Соответственно, примеров у него в базе данных огромное количество и отрисовать такое он сможет спокойно.
Что-то более специфичное, тут могут возникать вопросы.
Так или иначе, он на 90% всю базу закрывает и отрисовывает экраны нормально.
За исключением, опять же, тех мелочей, о которых мы говорили в предыдущих уроках.
Когда он сбоит, когда у нас есть различные режимы наложения, когда у нас есть векторные фигуры, которые между собой как-то наслаиваются.
То есть, может быть, там используются режимы вычитания и так далее.
То есть, со всем таким, что расположено абсолютно, что имеет режимы наложения.
В общем, такие элементы визуализации.
Он с ними работает плохо.
И плохо потом работает в прототипировании, когда пытается их воссоздать.
Это можем сразу отметить.
И то, что тебе в любом случае придется делать руками, это, во-первых, добавлять логотип бренда, добавлять реальные изображения, различные фото.
Ну и если они нужны тебе внутри фигмы, то собирать прототипы, устанавливать связи и так далее.
Я, как обычно, просто закинул директиву, начал ее выполнение и здесь у нас пошли разные этапы.
Брифование, согласование и так далее.
Тут он определил, что у нас есть эти варфреймы.
Мы помним, что мы много уроков назад их делали и, тем не менее, они у него в памяти не потерялись.
Он запросто их нашел благодаря тому, что мы пользуемся средой.
Он определил, какие экраны у нас есть, из чего они состоят.
Здесь, например, хедер.
В каждой есть секции.
В каждом экране разделение на колонки, конфиг, тулбар, баланс виджет и так далее.
Короче, все это он отметил и уже знает, что ему тут понадобятся компоненты.
Также отдельно отметил, что у нас есть иконки и логотипы.
Хочешь ли ты их заменить?
Я сказал, нет, можем двигаться дальше, пока это не нужно.
Вот.
Проходят разные этапы.
Он начал все это дело отрисовывать.
Потом был этап модернизации того, что уже есть, дорисовки.
Перед этим он, разумеется, показал, что он уже собрал, что у нас все работает.
И после чего уже я на свое усмотрение начал просить его просто дорабатывать эти экраны, что-нибудь туда добавлять и так далее.
Все это необязательно, но я отдельно еще это докинул в его директиву, чтобы вам потом это делать не пришлось.
И давай посмотрим, какого результата нам удалось добиться.
Смотри, вот первый вариант, это как демонстрация того, что будет, если вот эти дополнительные четыре фазы модификации того, что он собирает, не использовать.
Это тот узнаваемый wireframe, который у нас был на одном из предыдущих уроков, посвященных wireframe.
И выглядит здесь все достаточно просто, да, в нашей дизайн-системе, да, аккуратно, но мы видим, что здесь достаточно данных, которые хотелось бы визуализировать получше.
Вот, например, у нас VPN, IMS и идут параметры через точку, там его IP, операционная система, город, где он находится и так далее.
Можно ли этим пользоваться?
Ну, в теории, да, но, конечно, от экрана какого-то настоящего приложения ты ожидаешь большего.
В целом, у нас еще есть тени, да, они тоже как бы скрасили бы впечатление.
Разные цвета, тут много мест, где отмечены иконки, иконки он не добавил.
В общем, получится достаточно сухо и сыро, поэтому визуал нужно дорабатывать.
После того, как он визуал дорабатывает, он внедряет какие-то визуализации графиков, их примеры, внедряет тени, иконки, красит некоторые блоки, выглядит уже живее.
Структурная информация приятнее, и это больше похоже на какое-то реальное приложение.
Но, помимо того, что мы как бы просто все это дело раскрашиваем, мы дорабатываем еще смысловой нагруз.
Опять же, здесь вопрос визуализации вот, например, этих данных.
Поэтому наши директивы предусматривают и это, и дорабатывают структурно все наши экраны.
Как это выглядит после полного прогона директивы.
Я выделил под это один основной экран дашборда, и здесь видим, он уже предусмотрел, чем вот этот экран дашборда заполнить помимо того, что у нас уже есть.
Да, самое основное - сервера и мониторинг самых основных показателей.
Это сколько у нас денег осталось, сколько у нас серверов, и через сколько нам нужно будет еще раз заплатить за них.
Но смотри, как он здесь поработал вот с этими карточками.
Сюда он добавил иконки серверов, здесь визуализировал это через такие теги.
Но тут да, вот есть как бы нюанс, есть такая мелочь, которую можно поправить по вертикали, тоже поставим в общем пиксели, чтобы было аккуратнее.
Также, поскольку у нас здесь еще есть кнопка "Все серверы", то можно здесь поставить fill, потому что они всегда одно пространство будут занимать.
Здесь эту штуку тоже можно, здесь вот это тоже можно поправить по высоте, здесь там, я не знаю, например, сжать количество этих блоков.
Вот, и все уже у нас аккуратно.
Тут также дополнительные какие-то появились сущности, последние операции, иконки, цвета, которые демонстрируют это зачисление либо списание.
И здесь также это все уже привязано к семантическим переменным и так далее.
Но тут у нас тоже визуализация графиков, это все можно дополнить, просто не стало времени и токены тратить на то, чтобы это дорисовывать.
То есть, по сути, наша директива не только вот в тупую перерисовывает, это еще один, как бы такой последний пункт перепроверки, а все ли у нас есть, готово ли у нас это все дело к визуализации.
И теперь заключительный раз, когда мы используем руками, а когда пользуемся к лодам, mcp и так далее.
Через mcp мы делаем, когда нужно сделать много, и он это точно сделает быстрее.
Руками правим точечные какие-то моменты.
Где-то у нас высота не так выглядит, где-то цвет, возможно, не тот он поставил по акцентности.
Это все руками доделать дело 5 секунд.
Поэтому мучить его совершенно не обязательно для этого.
Можно, если у тебя избыток лимитов, но смысла в этом особо не вижу.
Не с его помощью.
Это все, что связано с прототипированием именно внутри фигмы, с отрисовкой иконок.
Иконки он тебе вряд ли хорошо в фигме нарисует.
Он может сделать SVG иконку, вставить ее в фигму, но я бы тут сильно на него не полагался.
Ну и когда нам нужны разные эффекты и режимы наложения, внедрения изображений, с этим всем лучше справляться самому, потому что он будет делать это долго и не факт, что сделает это хорошо.
На этом все. В качестве домашней работы тебе нужно будет также прогнать директиву, пройти брифинг, проанализировать, что действительно стоит собирать сейчас, а что не нужно, что можно добавить в твой визуал.
И ты можешь ограничиться в этом, наверное, одним-двумя экранами, потому что токенов это жрет приличное количество.
Также хочу отдельно отметить, что перед тем, как всем этим делом заниматься, я создал отдельную страницу screens, экраны, скопировал на нее ссылку и отправил ее вместе с директивами с указанием того, что экраны нужно собирать именно тут.
Формат сдачи, как обычно, ссылка на твой Figma-файл. Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания и до встречи в следующем видео.